il y a très peu de temps dans un gymnase
pas si lointain
une poignée de passionnés qui s'adonnent
chaque semaine au plus ancestrales art
jedi le combat au sabre laser
donc aujourd'hui révision pour passer
votre examen de chicha la semaine
prochaine donc on va tous se mettre en
position de garde que vous connaissez
tous passés à l'attaqué une du co ici ce
sont les premières années ceux qui
débutent les padawan diraient les plus
rompus à l'univers star wars
on apprend en fait ce qu'on appelle le
chichon qui est la forme de base donc
dans le folklore star wars c'est ce
qu'on apprend très tôt padawan c'est une
forme qui permet d'avoir neuf attaques
et 9 défense et ensuite c'est la base de
plusieurs formes qu'ils apprendront
débat national ces mouvements inspirés
de plusieurs arts martiaux sont calqués
sur ceux des films mieux le fondateur du
club les avais appris auprès du
chorégraphe des deuxième et troisième
prix logis lui même mais ici ils sont
utilisés pour créer une discipline
sportive
une part des changes c'est à dire que je
vais porter une attaque que je vais
ressentir une défense je veux dire ah
d'accord sur ce type d'attaqué il réagit
comme ça donc la faiblesse va être ce
site lecture de l'adversaire il ya une
triple fonction pour quelqu'un qui
serait pas fan de savoir s'il aurait
autant de plaisir que faire du combat de
cannes donc ce que faisait les
gentlemans du 19e siècle ou des scream
traditionnelle et je pense qu'on allait
ou de l'aïkido selon selon les formes on
a ce plaisir-là de l'échangé de le
change construit le fan de star wars en
plus à tout le folklore et le plaisir
qui va avec
parmi les pratiquants il y a les fans
forcément comme gabriel qui manie le
sabre laser depuis un an il a découvert
le club à la sortie de l'épisode 9 au
cours d'une démonstration
était tous à bianco spiritus à moi je
suis totalement fan de star wars et puis
quand j'ai découvert je suis comme ça si
vous avez des lames tous ces machins ils
sont dit tiens bon on fait des combats
je vois moi c'est exactement ce que je
veux faire en fait c'est tout chercher
un truc qui me clairement qu'ils me
défouler
c'est un univers où je me sens bien en
fait mais il n'y a pas forcément besoin
d'être le plus grand fan de la galaxie
pour s'adonner à ces disciplines
a la base je suis pas du tout fan de
star wars c'était vraiment juste pour
suivre mon mari je me foutais un peu de
lui je pensais que c'était des gamins à
jouer à star wars avec des sabres laser
et au final
au final n'ont pas c'est un vrai sport
un vrai sport qui compte 150 clubs en
france et qui depuis 2010 9 est affilié
à la fédération d'escrimé
il pourrait donc se retrouver un jour
grâce à la force aux jeux olympiques